I mentioned earlier in the show if you
get a chance go to Yahoo Sports and read
what Charles Robinson has been writing
he specializes in the NFL and
investigative reporting is most recent
articles just like the NFL's deal with
jay-z the Colin Kaepernick workout looks
like a PR trap also NFL is giving Colin
Kaepernick reasons to pull out of
Saturday's Pro Day and Charles kind
enough to join us on short notice
Charles well done with the the columns
how if you were gonna get put a
percentage on this Pro Day happening on
Saturday what would you put it out right
now I think the chances are better today
honestly I yesterday if you had asked me
that I would have said that particularly
yesterday night I would have thought
that it was more likely to not happen
than happen but after having some
conversations this morning you know I
think that I think Colin Kaepernick
wants to stand by his tweet that this is
something that you know he's been
waiting for for you know almost three
years now and that regardless of how the
NFL wants to structure this and whether
or not they want to turn over the list
of who will be attending whether or not
it's you know a guy like Joe Philbin
who's you know running the on-field
drills who doesn't really have the
background that's necessarily dovetails
with what Colin Kaepernick does best I
think he just wants to go out there and
put on a show and show that hey look I'm
I wasn't kidding when I said I was ready
for this and if you want to do it on
short notice and every other thing you
want to throw out this I'm gonna go out
here in persevere and show teams that
I'm serious about actually wanting to
play another film but also it's I mean
if it's hastily formed and you know hey
we're gonna tell the Select NFL writers
get ready for something on Tuesday and
then Kaepernick finds out then like why
why does it feel like it's under this
this cloak of secrecy sounds like
there's no full transparency and and
Kaepernick was just saying you know if
you're giving me the chance then give me
the real chance and it comes back to the
question that I've been asking all
morning long does the NFL want Colin
Kaepernick to succeed
I I think it's a legitimate question I
mean it the the way this entire thing
was rolled out there's when you talk to
NFL teams about it you know I had a
chance to talk to a couple of guys in
personnel you know who would be
attending this and I said did you know
this was coming like are you kidding me
they're like no we we pretty much found
out you know some people in our office
found out via the memo but there were
other people who saw it you know it
Twitter first before you know any of us
in the building knew that this was even
gonna happen you know it's everything
about this as you said I mean it
suggests sat the NFL either doesn't want
him to succeed or the way this was
approached I think there's an argument
that the league thought he could say no
that he could sit there and say look
this is there's too many adverse you
know circumstances surrounding this you
drop it on the last minute you know four
days the travel not giving you know an
idea of who's going to attend this
there's just a litany of things that
suggest that the NFL saw this as and
that's what I wrote initially that the
NFL saw this is something where if he
says yes then it takes the the question
off the books about him never being
worked out he can't say that anymore if
he says no well hey you know what we
gave him a chance and he turned it down
you know now we've kind of basically
dropped our anchor on this and and we're
at least taking off is his best foothold
has always been no one's worked me out
we're at least taking that off the table
so no I think asking that question is
extremely legitimate and that's why you
have NFL players even a guy like Malcolm
Jenkins who has not always been
necessarily on the same pages as Colin
Kaepernick in terms of the methods of
how they've gone about their business
has questioned the legitimacy behind
this he's Charles Robinson senior writer
for Yahoo Sports what's more important
the actual workout or the interview with
Colin Kaepernick that's a great question
you know I think for some teams it's
gonna be the interview you know I think
it's I think the curiosity there's
definitely a curiosity that's what's
interesting when you talk to some people
across the league who have not seen him
a throw and and haven't spoken to him
maybe ever or or have not spoken him in
a
of years even going back to you know
when he was drafted out of Nevada
there's definitely a curiosity about
what his motivations are where his
head's at and then you know what he
looks like physically I had a chance to
talk to somebody late last night from
one of the teams that will be attending
and he said look what's interesting to
me is he said I went to his Instagram
account I looked at some of these
workout videos and he said he does look
physically like the player I remember
when he was at his peak you know he was
a pretty big guy like he was a very you
know sturdily built for a quarterback
particularly up top strong big arms all
these things and he said there was a
point in his career where he suffered
some injuries late with the 49ers and
you saw the weight loss you know you saw
his size diminish and it led you to
question you know whether or not he
could still be a durable player he said
I see the player that was once a durable
NFL quarterback he said I would like to
see what does he look like out you know
throwing the football and where's he at
physically so I think it's there are
different teams who want to see
different things but there's no doubt
the the interview and where his head's
at where his motivations are at and and
how he answers the question of you know
how he'll compete if he were brought
into a team structure I think a lot of
teams will find that to be one of the
pivotal you know parts of this yeah I I
didn't think he was gonna get rescind
for the last couple of years Charles I I
think that he's going to get signed
again I and I don't know why I'm not
basing this off anything I I originally
threw it out like the Patriots would be
the team that I could see bringing him
in and bringing him in for one sole
purpose is to get us ready for the
rematch with the Ravens in the
postseason I don't know there's other
teams where he could play and you know
he could start but I I just I don't know
do you get the feeling he's gonna be on
a roster by the end of the year I I
think it's interesting when you when you
talk to teams I I guess it was what was
interesting to me is teams could have
set this up themselves in Italy you know
we can talk about the bay it's a league
providing cover but it's so weird if it
really has happened the way that you
know you you're hearing this backstory
from the NFL that a you know there were
teams that were interested in they're
reaching out
and they didn't like the way that things
had gone down between he and Seattle and
he in Baltimore when he was a free agent
and it's still odd to have teams
reaching out to the NFL to arrange for
cover and then you have like why would
other teams then show up to watch him if
they're not interested mostly providing
cover for other teams design him it's
just that it's a weird set of
circumstances but that said when I when
I talk to some people I I was struck by
the fact that there is some curiosity
that there are guys that are like hey I
want to see him I want to see if he can
throw like you know this stuff on the
Instagram I don't care about any of that
they're like I want to I want to see him
in a structured workout go through a
passing the scripted passing program and
push him a little bit and kind of see
where he's at he's still relatively
young particularly when we consider how
you know long quarterbacks can play
nowadays so I I would say that I'm a
little more optimistic that there is an
opening there and and auditioning to me
that you mentioned the Patriots because
when you look at all the teams that are
showing up you know Denver showing up
and I'm like tits
that's dubious like it's pretty clear
that Denver's not really interested but
the Patriots yeah that's a team where
I'm like I could see Bill bill you know
zigs when when people expect him to zag
and he's this is exactly the kind of guy
where you're like maybe he gives him a
little something extra that bill always
looks for down the stretch and yeah I
know hey great stuff Charles will be
reading thanks for joining us absolutely
thanks for having Dan that's Charles
Robinson senior writer for Yahoo Sports
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]